j'aimerais que vous nous fassiez un truc
vous c'est que vous vous retournez et
vous comment c'est comme si c'était le
journal de 20h la maîtresse elle est
belle avec rexel a fait de ma tronche
alors retourné vous retourner vos mails
ou pas mais attention oui on vous a réel
et vous comment c'est comme si c'était
le journal de 20h attendant bébé elle va
être bien vivement bruce toussaint à
lauras moussa à tous les 20 ans j'ai pas
le journal les anr est au pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va
et les mecs je pense que oui on les dit
david youssef ailleurs la dga c'est pas
une vie c'est pas mal c'est mon but
attention marzouki nourrissons et vous
nous faites le début c'est i télé c'est
le matin ben quoi quand on vous appelle
vous démarrez votre espace en ligne
dames kim bien sûr la routine
bref on va vous appeler ouais ouais
bruce willis s'est passé là-bas c'est là
bas oui bonjour à tous
je vous
[Applaudissements]